I decided to develop a camera
with an exposure time of 100 years.
Now the camera is not your ordinary device
it's not your iPhone for instance. It is
in fact the simplest of cameras because
anything complicated is liable to break.
And I probably couldn't make it anyway.
So what I have done, starting in Berlin,
was to make a camera that is a pinhole camera.
In other words it's a camera that
lets in very little light through a
pinhole that is focused onto what
ordinarily would be a piece of film.
Well any film is going to spoil relatively
quickly. I've managed to with my own
cyanotype chemistry make exposures that
are on the order of perhaps a week. And
I know people who have managed to do so
I believe up to a couple years through
various tricks. And that's well and good.
But it certainly is by no means
a century. So the way in which this camera
works is it doesn't use ordinary film.
It uses something much more common and
much more simple which is ordinary
black paper. Now if you think about a book
on your coffee table, for instance, and you
look at it... you'll see that it
probably has started to fade or a poster
on your wall. And it will continue to do so
in sunlight well the same thing will
happen for a piece of ordinary black paper.
But if you put that paper into a camera
letting in very little light through
a pinhole, what you're doing is you're
projecting the scene in front of the
camera. But light is projected on to the
paper in a way that the paper will
gradually bleach, very very slowly taking
in an image. The image will not be static
because presumably whatever you're
photographing is going to change over
that 100-year period. So if you think
about if the camera is out in a city
and there are some small houses. And those
houses get torn down after 20 years and a
skyscraper gets built up in their place
and is there for the next 80,
just to simplify. You would see
the shadow, a ghost of those houses, against
the bolder skyscraper sort of like
in sports photography when you see a
basketball player moving very fast
across a court where the court is very
boldly in place in view and the
basketball player is sort of ghostly. And
so what you end up with is not so much
a photograph as you end up with a movie
all in a single frame of that full span
of a hundred years. Now why that
interested me in Berlin was watching
the city undergoing rapid and rampant
development--so incredibly fast that
every time that I went back there it was as if
it were a different city. And so I
started to think about how you might
make a camera that would be able to
take that in. That would serve as a sort of a
surveillance camera in the hands
of those most affected by everything that
we do, all the decisions that we make, yet
least powerful to make any decisions:
that is to say those not yet born. And so
the idea in Berlin was to build these
cameras as surveillance cameras that
could be taken out into the field
and hidden away and in a hundred years
the images would be brought in. So
I worked with a gallery called "team titanic"
we built a hundred of them. And we then made
them available to anyone who wanted
to take one and to hide it. If you wanted to
take one you gave a deposit of 10 euros,
took a camera, hid it somewhere.
Anywhere that you wanted in Berlin didn't tell
anybody. Except when you got to be
very old you would tell a child where you had
put it. Or you would write it into your will.
And in a hundred years
those children then grown up would bring
the cameras back to team titanic where
they would get the 10 euro deposit.
No guarantees about what it's worth.
But nevertheless you would get something
in return and then there would be
an exhibition. A hundred years of change, all
in that image. And so the idea was really
to engage people. To engage the children of
today in a way that they were actively
taking a part in putting these cameras
out in the world. And not only those who
were directly involved, but also those
who heard about it, who read about it.
And it was all over the place we got it into
the newspapers. We got a conversation
going about this. That the cameras
became a sort of a constant presence
and remain for the next 100 years a sort of
constant presence in the city. Think of them as
sort of black boxes in that sense.
That are documenting and therefore are, well,
it's a sort of documentary photography
in the worst possible way.
Because documentary photographers are not
supposed to interfere. These photographs
manifestly do interfere because
you don't know where they are and yet you
know that you could be being watched.
And so the decisions that you make
you perhaps feel a little bit more
accountable for those and perhaps feel
some sort of a relationship to those
in the far future.